hello freak [ __ ] how does it feel to
not have to worry about we were talking
about this before the podcast and not
have to worry about weight cutting
anymore to be able to eat healthy
not not banged up anymore man it's been
really really nice you know I was kind
of envisioned after even wrestling in
college like having a break and then you
know went 14 years longer to fighting
people but I mean it is really nice to
be able to I mean you go train I train
when I want to but I don't do this stuff
I don't want to I I get in and do the
grappling around so whatnot but I just
feel so much better yeah you do look
healthy but you made out of retirement
perfect and I mean like you had a long
career but you didn't get too banged up
like you just and you picked the right
time you went out with a win with a
quality opponent like right off into the
sunset I know man I don't know I was
little luck a little bit of it just felt
right though you know I mean the last
fight went out to what 5 million people
on big Fox it was the first fight in my
hometown in the new arena that's like
the heart and like revives our town
you know we had Cody fighting for the
belt like coming right up and and you
know it was just perfect man yeah you
got you timed it good you timed it good
you know it's nice it's nice to see
someone do it the right way and I hope
other guys coming up can can learn from
you in that regard well one of the
things I thought about was first and
foremost like I've been rocked more in
the last two and a half years of my
practice and live fights that I had in
my entire career which is you know a lot
of different factors probably you know
how many times you're rolling the dice
you know you get hit in the head a bunch
of different times things are loosened
up a little bit you get a little bit
older guys are getting better I got Cody
garb rants in the gym and Chad Mendez's
and and you know Lance Palmer's these
guys that hit heavy so you know I was
just like that's one factor then I lost
two fights in a row for the first time
in my career ever even though it was a
decision to Dominic in a decision to uh
what's his name and gone Riviera Jim
Revere Jim Riviera and it was like kind
of lackluster losses but nonetheless is
like you know just like you know what
I'm not going I'm gonna
I'm gonna call this one a good time
smart very smart man and I really do
hope more guys learn you know and pay
attention to how you did it and do it
the right way because like how do you
guys feel about like you know you seem
like a lot of these guys are going over
to Bellator and I think Bellator signed
some really good fighters
you know like Rory MacDonald lorenz
larkin and they've got I mean Gegard
Mousasi they got some great talent over
there but they also have guys that are
you know late forties fifties still bad
stuff yeah freak show stuff for me we
always talk about this I told your eye I
said if I start getting [ __ ] up in
there knocked out like I'm gonna keep
fighting like make sure that you pulled
me away like be the homie that says hey
sits me down like hey let's do a
different career path you know if I
always say that you know that's one
thing I say you know we were fighters
were always gonna fight through it and
obviously a lot of different reasons now
financially or mm-hmm sometimes it's
just hard to walk away what do you do
when you know the next chapter your life
people don't set that up you know like
I'm fortunate I have a lot of you know
good people around me so you know I'll
have different avenues to go and I
always tell them hey if I start getting
[ __ ] up in there tell me it is also
important to understand that the kind of
intensity and focus that's required to
be a great fighter you could do anything
you really absolutely just apply it yup
just apply just figure out what that
next thing is gonna be and go out it the
same way you went out your championship
career yeah I always tell these guys you
know we do talks before and after
practice and it's like a feather in the
cap mentality like everything we've got
guys in there that won't see the UFC
daylight I mean they'll never see step
foot in the Octagon but they do get a
little bit of pride whether it was one
day it was ten years or whatever being a
part of that team and that's something
they they add to their life they take on
and we'll the next thing somebody just
comes in for a week some guys are are
gonna be you know make it to the big
show some guys are gonna be world
champions some guys gonna be Hall of
Famers you know and and and that's
that's whatever your journey is that's a
proud thing you can put in the feather
in the cap and move on or whatever
you're doing next but but it's it's a
bigger picture and it's like journeys
never over it's just always changing
[Applause]
[Music]